a et non c'est
R
s non
plus
g tu es sûr que c'est un G oui n'est pas
un G et
C
m Paul faut
conceevoir ten prie voilà tu es
astigmate hyper m trop mais tu vas voir
ça va aller enfin non non tu vas pas
voir mais ça va aller quand même
hein tu vois ce que je veux
dire du coup tu veux me dire quoi
c'était en fait juste pasah pour te dire
que que quoi euh bah
oui bah en fait c'était juste bah pour
te dire que tu es bizarre sais tu vas
jamais t'en sortir dans la vie en
parlant comme ça Paul puis bah les
filles elles aiment pas les mecs
timides mais en fait c'était juste
dommage je
t'aime mais Paul tu es en train de lire
ça fait une demi-heure que je te cherche
c'est ton tour là faut y aller j'ai pas
envie d'y aller comment ça tu as pas
envie j'ai pas mais non c'est ça qui
donne de la force dans la vie
non traîné jusque là
pardon
allez les autres ils te verront plus de
la même manière
après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je des de la c'est pour t' je ti je
vous PL
PL PL plaqu pl